[Musique]
dans le cadre de la troisième édition
des résidences d'artistes l'artothèque a
accueilli eric lebaut pendant plusieurs
mois qu une résidence original qui
propose de mettre en résonance de la
musique vivante dans un lieu de
conservation est d'offrir aux visiteurs
en voyage onirique au snuc intitulé
histoire havanaise cette résidence
s'inscrit dans la suite d'ateliers
d'écriture de chansons donné par
l'artiste
donc ça a commencé par
une étape d'écriture en
au mois d'août à peu près je suis maker
quotidiennement et puis ensuite bat g
j'ai pris des oeuvres de l'artothèque
complètement au hasard c'est sont des
gens que j'ai rencontrés au hasard des
amis de ses amis des gens perdus de vue
les choses comme ça et je les faisais
choisir le font en fait l'un pour tech
des tableaux voilà ça m'a permis de
développer encore d'autres d'autres
aspects de rencontrer des photographes
de travailler donc avec marie guiraud
qui expose de ce côté
son travail est en fait ce sont des
photos qu'elle m'en envoyer
quotidiennement et pour lesquels
j'écrivais un texte quotidiennement
voilà un texte par jour et comme
l'univers est assez onirique assez
fantomatique
j'ai eu envie de développer en fait ce
travail sur l'image et d'aller peut-être
rêvé de faire un film en fait voilà
est-ce que ça qu'il ya la dernière pièce
où il ya une vidéo projetée
alors c'est des plans statique rien
encore et travailler mais c'était pour
montrer en fait le cheminement qui part
d'un une volonté d'écrire eca qui
débouche sur les creillois écrire un
film est d'en réaliser évidemment en
tant que musicien à la bande son un
dispositif du département mis en place
en 2010 est de soutien à la création
artistique et de valorisation du
patrimoine
donc le passif des résidences d'artistes
et de bd un artiste a créé et surtout de
faire en sorte qu'ils puissent
rencontrer du public
dialoguer avec les commentaires des
visiteurs et faire en sorte qu'il y ait
une meilleure appropriation et
connaissances des oeuvres de columbia
qui l'a créée donc les résidences
d'artistes c'est un dispositif original
qui a été mise en place par le
département il ya un peu plus de leur on
est aujourd'hui à la quatrième édition
danse est un dispositif qui fonctionne
très bien et encore une fois les
artistes en résidence ont créé deux
heureux de bénéficier d'un
accompagnement de financer bien
évidemment mais aussi eu un accueil dans
la structure culturelle
le résultat du travail d'eric le bo sera
visible à l'artothèque jusqu'au 3
juillet prochain
[Musique]